Digamos que alguien es dueño
de una tienda de mascotas
y que esta tienda
es muy peculiar
pero de hecho que es muy poco común,
en donde solo va a haber
tres tipos de animales,
ok,
entonces por un lado sabemos que tiene gatos
y al número de gatos la vamos a denotar
con la letra "g",
muy bien,
También vamos...
vamos a
a tener que esta tienda,
tiene perros...
perros y al número de perros,
pues también vamos
a denotarlo ahora con la letra "p"
y además,
esta tienda tiene osos,
¿Ok?
Por eso es que es
bastante peculiar esta tienda,
y bueno platicando con el dueño
quizás estábamos tomándonos un cafecito ¿qué sé yo?
Nos dice que tiene
que el número de gatos,
pues vamos a ponerlo
con el mismo color...
que el número de gatos es muy...
es mayor,
que el número de perros
y que también tiene
más perros que osos,
y eso, eso está bien porque...
porque sería muy raro que tenga
más osos que cualquier otro de estos animales.
¿Ok?
Entonces basado en esto,
nos preguntan,
¿Cuál de las siguientes dos expresiones es mayor,
si
osos entre la suma de gatos con perros y osos,
o bien 1/3?
¿Muy bien?.
Entonces te invito a que pases un poco el vídeo
y tú mismo razones
¿Cuál crees que sería la respuesta?
Puede ser que esta expresión
sea más chica que 1/3,
puede ser también que sea más grande,
o puede que sean iguales,
o definitivamente
con esta información que nos dan,
no podemos saberlo.
Entonces si...
si ya lo,
lo pensaste vamos a continuar
y veamos, que realmente esta expresión de aquí
es muy importante, porque
esto que es el número de osos dividido
entre el número de gatos,
más el número de perros,
más el número de osos,
pues es la proporción
o la fracción que hay de,
de osos respecto a todos los animales,
si sumamos estas 3,
estamos diciendo
todos los gatos,
más los perros, más los osos
pues este es el número total de animales que hay,
y si aquí estamos tomando solo los osos,
estamos diciendo
¿qué fracción...
qué fracción de osos hay en la tienda?
Entonces la fracción de osos
¡Muy bien!
Entonces...
La pregunta es
¿Qué si este número es
más grande, menor o igual que 1/3?
Puede que no podamos decir,
entonces voy a dar varios argumentos en...
a lo largo de los siguientes videos
hay muchas formas de ver esto,
y en este video voy a hacer una forma visual,
¿ok?
Entonces voy a pegar,
digamos un esquemita,
digamos que tengo este esquemita,
muy bien,
Y entonces digamos que este cuadrado
representa todos los animales
¿Y qué pasa si la proporción
de osos es más grande que 1/3?
Déjenme ponerlo así
¿Qué pasa si la proporción
es más grande que 1/3?
Entonces,
digamos que estas líneas son 1/3
y ahora los osos,
digamos abarcan un poco más,
digamos que los osos abarcan toda esta,
toda esta fracción,
muy bien, entonces
sabemos, por lo que nos dice el dueño,
que hay más perros que osos,
entonces la proporción de perros
tiene que pasar de 1/3,
entonces, si esto era un poco más de 1/3
esto también va a ser todavía más,
digamos que abarca todo esto,
muy bien.
Y ahora bien
nos dice también el dueño
que hay más gatos que perros
¿pero qué creen?
aquí ya nos queda algo más chico que 1/3
entonces, vamos a tener
digamos toda esta región
y pues resulta que ya nos pasamos
entonces, esto no puede ser posible
no puede ser posible,
muy bien,
Vamos a ver
entonces otra forma que puedes
que puedes verlos,
digamos, si la proporción de osos,
es más grande que 1/3,
quiere decir
que entre gatos y perros tengo...
que la proporción entre gatos y perros
pues debe ser más...
debe ser más chico que 2/3,
entonces alguno
tiene que ser más chico que 1/3
y eso no puede ser posible por esta relación
¿verdad?
Entonces
vamos a ver qué pasa
en el caso en que fueran iguales,
Digamos, pegamos otro de estos
¿Qué pasa si la proporción es igual a 1/3?
Ok,
vamos a ver ,
¿Qué pasa si la proporción es igual 1/3...
igual a 1/3?
Entonces aquí sobre esta línea
encimamos la proporción
que hay de osos,
muy bien,
encimamos la proporción que hay de osos,
y ahora nos dicen,
que hay más perros que osos,
entonces la fracción de los...
de los perros,
como no... como debe ser más grande que 1/3,
quizás ande por acá.
¿Ok?
Quizás ande hasta acá,
y tenemos exactamente ahora
el mismo problema que teníamos anteriormente,
cuando yo intento
poner aquí los gatos, pues en realidad
debe ser algo más grande que los perros,
y los perros se pasan de 1/3,
y aquí ya tengo menos que 1/3,
entonces, nuevamente,
este caso no es posible,
no va a ser posible este caso.
Ahora vamos a ver el último,
porque también podría ser que ninguno,
y entonces estemos llegando
a alguna contradicción
pero bueno,
vamos a ver que en este caso,
por ejemplo,
si... si la proporción de osos
es más chico que 1/3, digamos,
algo así,
no sé,
podríamos tener que la proporción de perros,
pues puede hacer exactamente 1/3 ¿no?
algo así,
Muy bien,
puede ser que sea algo así
y que la proporción de gatos sea,
pues este, este restante ¿no?
digamos este restante,
y entonces este sí fue un caso compatible,
si pudimos hacer que... que... que...
digamos,
poner a las tres proporciones en este...
en este caso
en donde es más chico que 1/3
¿ok? entonces en este caso si pudimos,
sí es creíble ¿verdad?
Otra vez, esta es la proporción de gatos
que hay entre todos los animales,
es decir entre esta suma,
acá ponemos la proporción
de perros que hay
entre todos los animales
y finalmente ponemos la proporción
que hay de osos...
voy a ponerlo...
con el color adecuado...
de osos,
respecto a todos los animales
y esto sí fue creíble ¿verdad?
de hecho si pudimos hacer
que esta expresión sea menor que 1/3,
y este argumento visual, con este argumento
puedes darte cuenta que la expresión
tiene que ser menor a 1/3,
entonces en el siguiente vídeo daré argumentos analíticos que no necesitan de dibujos,
para demostrar que en efecto
tiene que ser menor que 1/3.